Have you been following Dr. McCullough's new articles about how doing too much keto or fasting
damages or metabolism and causes stress via cortisol? It's like he's done a 180 degree turtle
as a vice. He said it's better for me to try to get energy from glucose.
Well, you know, you do have to be careful with, you know, anybody who follow it. Dr.
McCullough, I love him, you know, dearly. He's a great guy, but he jumps on his bandwagon
all the time. And you do have to be careful that, you know, he really pushes different things
really hard to sell things, which I don't like that about him. But I do agree with this point.
So when he was on the giant bandwagon, doing keto and fasting all the time for people who are
not cancer patients, I don't like those bandwages because you know, these are good for everybody.
And I don't think these diets are good for everybody. And you see books written on them that
everybody should do keto. You know, that's as the danger of Instagram and Facebook because somebody
who is doing something, let's say they're doing a keto diet, then they think that everybody should
do a keto diet. Not everybody's metabolism is set up to do a keto diet. They can't do a keto diet.
It wouldn't be healthy for them. Just like somebody who goes, who goes vegan, thinks everybody should
go vegan. The truth is vegan can be a healthy thing for people. And vegan can be the least healthy
thing for probably most people. So now the biggest craves is this carnivore diet. Everybody should
only be eating meat. Okay, whenever you have that word only in there, you should already should throw
red flag up in your mind. So I always go back. Okay, what's the thing that you kind of kind of put
things in perspective is God did put us in a garden. We are supposed to be eating vegetables. But
after the fall, he did give us meat to eat. And he did give us grains to eat. And he did say that
we're supposed to eat seeds and nuts and things. So to just cross these things off of our list
because of some some diet that's going around that some reputable doctor is pushing
I think it's wrong. You go back to biblical ways of how we're supposed to eat. Now granted,
our food has been adulterated and granted our grains have been so scorched and damaged. It's
crazy. And granted a lot of people have gluten sensitivities and they have antibodies to
be added in the end peptides and dairy and different dairy peptides and things. So you do have to
address those things because man is so destroyed our food supply. But God has allowed us to eat
everything. And we have to be in balance with all that we eat. Now everything might not be good
for everybody. But it doesn't mean that it's not something that is a bad thing to be doing.
So even a cancer is it okay for a cancer patient to be doing keto or fasting?
Well, you know what I've said about fasting and I know there's been there's disagreement out there
about how long a person should fast if they have cancer. And I've said that you probably shouldn't
be doing too many fasts over 24 hours if you have cancer. And how long should you be on a keto
diet if you have cancer? If you have a cancer that would be beneficial for a keto diet which is
typically like the brain cancers, it's not something you stay on the rest of your life either.
So it's it's about that balance. And you know, I have a long said too that you know,
we think about how food, how we grow food and you know, should we be eating more in season?
Should we be eating apples every day just because apples aren't good for us?
They may not. You know, so you know, we rotate our diet and rotate what we can eat.